you're going to learn the three steps to
help you tap into the power of
reflective listening skills and after
the tips you'll have the opportunity to
practice in real time with me so you
leave this video with some repetitions
and I'll give you some Pro tips at the
very end to help you improve on your own
from there be sure to look in the
description below for a list of all the
other videos on listening that I have
and a link to a free download on the top
5 essential communication skills for
professionals a basic definition of
reflective listening is to listen so you
understand what the person is saying and
then reflect or show the speaker that
you have understood them and this is why
reflective listening is so powerful
you're helping people feel heard and
understood I mean what price would you
put on that if somebody was really
hearing you and really understanding you
your reflective listening will also help
the other person get their own Clarity
that speaker has the opportunity to hear
themselves talk through an issue
sometimes all they need is a sounding
board and and listening like this builds
trust as well
let's talk about what reflective
listening is not it's not listening to
offer Solutions or advice obviously in
the course of a relationship it's
possible that advice may come out at
some point maybe even near the end of
the same conversation but giving advice
is not part of reflective listening
specifically so if you're a fixer like I
am sometimes reflective listening may be
a challenge for you you have to resist
the temptation to short-circuit the
listening process by jumping in with
advice before the other person truly
feels heard counselors and therapists
use reflective listening constantly I'm
not a therapist but reflective listening
can be used in your personal or family
relationships if you're a coach teacher
a supervisor or have co-workers you can
use elements of reflective listening in
lots of situations in fact you probably
already have moments where you make
reflective statements if your wife tells
you I finally mail that package to my
sister you might reply you did it if
your best friend says this project is
such a weight on my shoulders you might
reply it's a heavy load those are little
reflective statements and reflective
listening just Dives deeper into those
Waters
so here are three steps then we'll
practice and I'll finish with some Pro
tips
first your top priority will be to
listen carefully to understand the other
person we usually be listening for this
struggle but we could also be listening
for good news as well but just realizing
in the first place that the situation
calls for some reflective listening is
part of this unless you're a counselor
when a person walks in the room and
starts talking it's not always clear
what the other person needs from you so
as they talk listen to understand the
big picture you might be able to tell
that something's bothering them and they
may be generally upset for example you
can sense that they have a challenge or
difficulty that they're going through
that's usually a first indicator that
you should go into reflective listening
mode this is where you say to yourself
okay something's bothering them now
let's do some reflective listening and
see where it goes so I'm starting with
this point because for the average
listener it's not always obvious that a
conversation is going to go in this
direction you might normally be in
problem solving mode either way once you
realize the conversation calls for
reflective listening then listen for
anything that gives you clues about this
specific emotion or cognitive struggle
they are experiencing
second make a reflective statement what
exactly is bothering them your goal is
to understand their emotions at the same
level of sophistication that they're
expressing them if all you can express
is that they are feeling sad or down
then start there and reflect that but if
you can tell specifically that they are
anxious insecure or hurt then you'd
reflect back to them that level of
detail and Nuance maybe they're showing
signs of being conflicted having mixed
or layered emotions whatever it is you
take what you've noticed and make a
short statement that reflects back what
you're hearing the goal of your
statement is to show that you are trying
to understand them and also gives them
the opportunity to express themselves a
little further here are some starter
samples and we'll practice these
together in a couple of minutes I'm
going to fill in the emotions in these
samples but these samples work virtually
for any struggle it sounds like you're
feeling disappointed you're feeling
helpless about it you felt embarrassed
those reflective statements are all
about different emotional words the
speaker likely already said that you're
reflecting back to them but some people
are more likely to tell you about how
they think versus how they feel for
example they might be struggling
cognitively about a big decision or
trying to understand what's really going
on in a situation so here's what a
reflective statement sounds like when
the person is talking about what's on
their mind
you sound like you are weighing your
options you're not sure what to make of
all of it
it sounds like you're not ready to pull
the trigger
whether you're talking about their
emotions or their thoughts let's point
to some quick commonalities first these
are all statements which we'll explain
more in a minute they're also concise
and that's important because when you're
listening reflectively the other person
is the one talking almost the entire
time so keep your part concise
here are some additional sample starter
sentences
you're wondering if
for you it feels as if and then you
would of course fill in the rest of that
statement with whatever you're hearing
from them a common question uh here is
well what about asking them questions
well yes you can ask questions to
clarify your own understanding in the
course of the conversation that's part
of effective listening generally if
asking a question helps you understand
something better than ask you can also
make reflective statements and add a
small tag sentence here are some samples
let's assume you just made your
reflective statement and you can add a
brief tag am I tracking with you is that
accurate am I understanding you clearly
Tag questions can be a helpful way to
invite the other person to clarify or
tell more of their story but here's the
key the part of your statement that
mirrors their struggle is what makes
this reflective listening the act of
asking a question is not what makes it
reflective listening reflective
listening is all about restating and
clarifying what the other person has
already said in fact if this were a
video specifically for counselors we
would probably advise you not to ask a
lot of full-blown questions when you are
in reflective listening mode but Quick
Tag questions may be helpful if it fits
your style so here's the heart of it you
can see in the few samples we've looked
at so far you're a mirror you're not
telling them what you believe you're not
speculating about what you think they're
really feeling you're not directing or
steering the conversation to where you
think they should go or trying to
provide your own label or reframe their
experience you're not trying to change
their mind or help them see things
differently I say this because I know a
few people who almost immediately try to
reframe or spin anything I say to them
so then they know how to deal with it
better that's not reflective listening
remember what I said earlier you're not
trying to fix them a good reflective
statement simply restates or offers back
exactly what you believe the other
person is saying the basic impression
that you're getting there's a neutrality
to it it's concise reflective listening
isn't easy but when you see it in action
it's much more straightforward than most
people realize and third after you have
offered a reflective statement you go
right back into pure listening mode and
let them respond you zip it and let them
talk in other words
and this is really simply going back to
step one but I'm calling it step three
because this is a process and when you
see yourself going back into pure
listening mode that completes the circle
the other person is now responding to
what you have reflected your feedback
step three is not offering advice in
other words you're listening and giving
them the opportunity to process and
respond to your reflection the speaker
will usually react in one of two ways or
sometimes in between they'll either show
agreement yeah I'm incredibly frustrated
about it or maybe they'll clarify well I
wouldn't exactly say frustrated I'm just
annoyed that it's taking so long and
then the conversation would continue and
you would continue listening and even if
you're a little off in your reflective
statement you're still helping them
explore and increase their
self-understanding when you pitch back
what you've heard them say that gives
them the opportunity to look at what
they're experiencing at arm's length
they might even use the word anxious but
when they hear you reflect that word
anxious back to them they have the
opportunity to ask themselves is that
really what I'm feeling that reflective
process leads to more clarity for the
speaker as the conversation moves
forward you just go back into step
number one and repeat that a few times
in the conversation you listen carefully
to understand and get an impression of
what the person's feeling you make a
reflective statement and then you go
back into pure listening mode as they
respond let's practice this together
I'll summarize the situation I'm dealing
with and I'll put some sample reflective
statements up and you'll practice your
responses out loud with me again listen
for the feelings or the mental struggles
you're reflecting back what you hear
we'll do three quick scenarios from
easiest to most difficult scenario one
is the easiest let's say I come to you
to talk about why I've been so busy for
the last six months and how it's taking
a toll on me and somewhere in my story I
say I feel exhausted and overwhelmed in
your mind what am I feeling when I tell
you this story identify my emotion and
pause the video if you need to now
you'll reflect back what you've heard
say this out loud with me and fill in
the blank with whatever emotion you
sensed I was experiencing
it sounds like you are feeling
your
about that you feel
if you said anything close to exhausted
or overwhelmed then you're right on
track and that was designed to be the
easiest because I literally said I was
exhausted and overwhelmed you may have
had to adjust your sentences a little
bit to match what I was saying but if
you said anything close to exhausted or
overwhelmed then you're right on track
that was designed to be the easiest
because I literally said that I was
exhausted and overwhelmed but again even
if you used another word that would give
me the opportunity to clarify and keep
talking from there and even though these
statements sound really straightforward
if you were the person speaking and
somebody did reflective listening you
would feel heard and understood so it
doesn't sound like you're saying much
but it absolutely makes a difference to
them
scenario 2 is a little bit more
difficult in this scenario I won't label
my struggles as clearly
and I'll give you what I'm feeling and
you come up with an appropriate name and
reflect that back so here's the scenario
I've come to talk about an important
decision I need to make that's tearing
me up I don't know if I should take job
a or job B in your mind what do you
believe I am feeling identify my
struggle and pause the video if it helps
now reflect back what you heard say
these statements aloud with me and fill
in the blank with whatever emotion you
believe I'm experiencing
it sounds like you are feeling
your about that you feel
if you said anything like it sounds like
you are torn conflicted or ambivalent
then you're on the right track I didn't
tell you all the pros and the cons of
job a versus job B but you could tell
that I didn't know which one to choose
scenario three will be the most
challenging and here's a hint for you
sometimes people feel more than one
emotion maybe there's something positive
and something negative and that's what's
happening here in this scenario so here
it is I'm moving to a new location a few
hours away to take advantage of a
professional opportunity on the positive
side it could be huge for me I think I
like Sal in this role and that gets me
fired up on the negative side I don't
know anybody in this new community and
I'll be far from all my friends and
family I'm not sure if I'll be able to
handle that
so in your mind what do you believe I'm
feeling identify both sides of my
struggle and pause the video if it helps
now reflect back what you heard we're
only going to do this with one statement
so do your best to fill in the two
blanks allowed with me it sounds like
you are feeling both
and
now the good news is there are multiple
right ways to answer this here are a few
good ways to reflect back what you've
heard it sounds like you're feeling both
positives and negatives about this move
it sounds like you're feeling both
excited and nervous about this move and
even if you simply said you feel
conflicted or you feel mixed emotions
those are still pretty good reflective
listening statements and feel free to
rewind and practice the three scenarios
again because sample starter sentences
can be used for almost any situation and
it'll help you get repetitions here are
some Pro tips to help you get better at
this as you move forward first reflect
back at the same level of nuance they
are expressing reflective listening can
feel so simplistic at first that you may
feel stupid saying these reflective
statements to you it might seem really
obvious to say you're feeling anxious or
it sounds like you're feeling depressed
and on the one hand that might be true
if the person is talking about their
struggle for five minutes and you
oversimplify it too much by saying you
feel bad
then yes Einstein I feel bad that's so
obvious it's probably not helpful to
avoid that overly simplistic feeling do
your best to understand and reflect back
to them at the same level of
sophistication that they are showing you
that might mean you reflect back the
various reasons for how they're feeling
or reflect back the most pivotal details
of what they've just said just be sure
to be concise and not take over the
conversation and that takes practice now
on the other hand you might be surprised
at how helpful reflecting a basic
emotion can be for some people I was
talking to somebody the other day who to
me seemed obviously depressed but they
never realized it themselves they told
me that their therapist had said to them
it seems like you're feeling depressed
and that was a very helpful reflective
moment for them in their therapy session
and that leads to Pro tip number two
build your vocabulary for emotional and
cognitive dilemmas for example you may
want to Google emotion wheel and you'll
see a circular diagram with basic
emotions on the inside of the wheel and
increasingly differentiated emotions
each layer moving outward so sad would
be a basic emotion but loneliness is a
more specific type of sadness scared is
a basic emotion but anxious or
embarrassed or more specific than scared
so as you improve your vocabulary of
emotions you'll be able to reflect back
the emotions that people are
experiencing with more Precision that
adds Clarity and adds value because the
other person will feel truly heard and
understood
and third reflective listening is truly
in art these are fundamental skills but
you will get better and better at those
skills the more you do them you might
feel a bit like a robot at first but
practicing will make it feel more
natural your timing will be better your
non-verbal cues will be better those are
good components of active listening and
other related skills that you'll get
better at with practice you may feel
more relaxed in time and that'll help
the speaker relax as well so go out
there and start practicing reflective
listening so you get better at it be
sure to download that free pdf I
mentioned about the five essential
professional communication skills that
all professionals should have and a list
of other listening skills that I've made
until next time thanks God bless and I
will see you soon